I'm Robert Wilson I won the 1978 Nobel
Prize in Physics for discovering cosmic
microwave background radiation which is
radiation left over from the Big Bang I
went to Bell Labs in 1963 and one of the
things we wanted to do was to make a
measurement of the minimum brightness of
the sky and that went horribly wrong we
kept making measurements and kept seeing
the same extra radiation but we were
scratching our heads trying to
understand where it might come from well
we worried about a pair of pigeons that
are living in the antenna and they had
dropped pigeon droppings all over the
inside and what we did was to get a have
a heart trap pigeons went in trapped
closed
we took the pigeons put them in a box
mailed them as far as way as we could in
the company mail to a guy who fancied
pigeons and he looked at them and said
these are junk pigeons and let them go
and before long they were right back
we had ruled out a man-made radiation
and I don't remember what else but any
other imperfections we might have been
able to think of we were really running
out of ideas when we heard about the
idea of radiation left over from the Big
Bang
what you're hearing now is a recording
that I made
and several years later but in a
fraction like fifteen percent of this
noise comes from the cosmic microwave
background radiation our understanding
is that the universe was created from a
very compact way and it had been
expanded ever since
the beautiful bay above tree or Tree of
Life is an African icon the bail Bob
fruit contains four times the potassium
of banana three times the vitamin C of
an orange and twice the calcium of
spinach but the bail Bob is an orphan
science has paid little attention to
this tree until now the African orphan
crops consortium is harnessing the power
of genetics for orphan crops the bail
Bob tree is the first of 101 plants to
have its genome sequence assembled and
annotated and the information will be
made available to all unrestricted where
millions of people are malnourished this
genetic data will help farmers provide
the food they need the genomes will
guide African plant breeders so they can
create crops that are higher yielding
water and nutrient use sufficient
resilient to climate change and full of
nutrition triggering a huge leap forward
for the diversity and sustainability of
the continents agriculture